that sex makes two fundamental errors I
think you know I it's people might might
feel some qualms about us having such a
vigorous debate about this but you know
my feeling is the poor deserve a
vigorous debate just as as much as a
rich country taxpayers vigorously debate
the best domestic programs and whether
they are working or not and just like we
vigorously debated whether Hurricane
Katrina victims were being helped or not
well I think we should vigorously debate
whether foreign aid victim the victims
of poverty are being helped by foreign
aid or not and so professor Sachs makes
two fundamental errors I think first is
with with Professor Sachs it's all about
the money
it's always about the money it's just
you know spend more money and that will
solve the problem but we've already seen
2.3 trillion spent and it has not solved
the problem you know two million babies
are still dying from dehydration
another million are still dying from
measles for lack of a simple vaccination
economic growth was was of economic
growth and living standards of the
average African was basically zero in
the four decades since independence
despite of Africa getting five hundred
and sixty eight billion dollars of that
2.3 trillion in foreign aid so we've
seen this movie already professor Sachs
and it didn't have a happy ending we've
seen the movie in which money was spent
and yet it didn't reach the poor and yet
he seems to want to reinvent the wheel
and say oh yes let's just spend more
money and not paying attention to the
history or we've already spent money and
it didn't reach the poor and then the
second mistake that I think he makes is
to assume that expert plans can solve
poor people's problems
you know his approach to ending world
poverty was to assemble 300 of the
world's leading experts on all fields of
that affect poverty on agriculture to
talk about green manure
and you know infant care to talk about
breastfeeding and infant formula and
agriculture to talk about
nitrogen-fixing leguminous trees to
restore it'll restore soil fertility and
got all these experts together and draw
up a an expert plan that was designed by
twelve task forces of three hundred
experts that produced a three thousand
page report and this is our expert plan
that we've devised in New York at UN
headquarters to end world poverty well
that's just ridiculous you know that's
not how you solve the problems of poor
people they're not something expert
plans that's not how the problems of
poor people have ever been solved
anywhere else you know the poor in Asia
who have escaped poverty were not
rescued by an expert plan they were
rescued by a market-driven free trade
group in economic growth we just have to
look at ourselves even the people of
West Virginia in my my home state we're
not rescued by an expert plan they were
rescued by American economic growth over
the last two centuries and even though
West Virginians are still only eighty
percent of the u.s. per capita income
it's a much much higher per capita
income you know 20 times higher than it
was at the time of our independence and
that's what rescued West Virginians out
of poverty
that's how poverty has always ended is
through private sector free-market
economic growth not through expert plans
devised by my experts who think that
they know poor people's problems better
than the poor people do themselves
well I think it's making it a two-sided
debate you know that Jeff's axis and
people who think like him have gotten
sort of a free pass for quite a while in
the media because you know their
intentions are definitely very good and
very very admirable
and people tend to give you a lot of
slack if you have good intentions
there's something about me that I'm not
willing to give people with good
intentions a lot of slack if they're not
getting good results you know I think if
the good intentions are to help poor
people I'd like to see intentions plus
results not just intentions and so far
we've seen lots and lots of intentions
and very little in the way of results
and I think it's time that we called the
Jeff's axes and the bonds of the world
on that I think the Jeffrey Sachs view
is actually pretty much a minority view
within the economics profession that it
requires some kind of top-down
administrative plan to solve poverty I
think myself is just being a spokesman
and a popularizer for the mainstream
economics view that the end of poverty
is achieved through through homegrown
free markets poor people are their own
best resource in escaping poverty they
are very resourceful they are already
conquering problems every day that are
many times greater than you or I ever
have to have to face
that's how resourceful they are and
they're surviving and they have a life
and I respect them I'm not going to be
patronizing and say I'm you know here I
am the 21st century of the white man's
burden coming in to earth to save you
which i think is the problem of people
like Jeff Sachs and Bono I want to be
helpful but I don't want to be
patronizing
you